this woman's door was kicked in by
police when she refused to go to
quarantine
others in shanghai smashed rotten
vegetables in the street
and performed so-called concerts with
their pots and pans to express their
frustration after weeks of life under
lockdown and china's most populous city
and economic capital
i've seen a lot of emotion a lot of
people angry a lot of people sad a lot
of people depressed a lot of people
um in despair in videos that bubbled up
online despite censor's efforts to take
them down acts of disobedience unusual
for china show new challenges for
chinese authorities as they double down
their policy trying to keep kova 19 out
of the country completely
the city-wide lockdown began in late
march as shanghai tackled thousands of
new cases a day the biggest outbreak
china has seen since the pandemic began
some compounds had already been in
lockdown before that
it's a city of 25 million people and
we've seen this remarkable stream of
footage come out of shanghai most of it
filmed by ordinary people amateurs on
their on their on their smartphones but
they do reflect frustrations that we've
all heard from people who are living
there in one video a resident refused to
cooperate with officials
the woman who filmed and posted this
video online says she tested positive
but the test needed to be reviewed
police eventually took her away to
quarantine
she didn't respond to requests for
comment but said in her post that the
police later fixed the door
for weeks shanghai residents have
expressed frustration online but more
protests have recently taken place in
the physical world
synchronized banging of crockery dubbed
the concerts have been organized
this prompted the government to accuse
unspecified foreign conspirators in
warnings via wechat and loudspeaker
announcements
[Music]
one sensitive issue that has infuriated
citizens during the lockdown has been
the supply of food these vegetables were
supposed to be distributed to hungry
families locked in their homes instead
they rotted
in this scene people can be seen
complaining to a police officer who
promises to investigate
these videos uploaded on platforms like
wechat and weibo have been taken down
and re-uploaded a number of times
authorities have promised more food and
vowed to punish those who've made
mistakes with supplies at least three
officials have been fired for being slow
to distribute food
these public flare-ups come as lockdowns
impact businesses large and small
factories for tesla apple and many
others were shut down for periods of
time during the lockdown and companies
warned of disruptions to their supplies
and while some people living and working
in the city have continued to receive a
salary from their employers others have
been left without pay
it's a very visible and high profile
city it's
a city where you have both blue collar
workers it's home to
many of the most important factories in
china producing autos and producing a
lot of other goods that are shipped
around the world it has the world's
largest port you also have
the white collar industries shanghai is
the financial center of china
after six weeks of lockdown and a brief
easing of rules for some residents to
buy groceries and medicine authorities
in shanghai have tightened restrictions
again even as covet 19 cases in the city
fall
shanghai officials have thanked
residents for their understanding and
cooperation
the head of the world health
organization said china should rethink
its strategy in a rare rebuke when we
talk about the zero
covet strategy
we don't think that it's sustainable
considering the behavior of the virus
now and what we anticipate
in the future
unswayed by the who china is sticking
with its policy of eradicating
covenanting completely saying any
relaxation of measures could allow the
virus to rebound
[Music]
you